oh by the way [ __ ] my pants while
running this morning oh yeah did you not
hard just then it was a shart I was
coming up a hill had nothing left and I
and I thought I had to fart and just BAM
I did that the other day of my house
yeah just a little squirt and what Jesus
Christ feels like such a failure but I
had some good farts before that that's a
problem yeah I got motivated yeah
because I had some vomit
you're on a roll had some Rumblers what
Jesus it was just me I didn't have to
cover up from nobody so I was pausing
and leaning into them a little [ __ ]
that's a shower but that is the ultimate
failure because your job as a human is
to provide for your family and not [ __ ]
your pants because there's times you
know like oh no I'm about to [ __ ] my
pants there's like there's a certain
alarm that goes off like when you're
like oh no no we're crunching a little
too hard here okay we got a problem here
boys we got a runner
[Music]
clamping down it's the same exact
feeling that you get is when you're
trying to hold come in you know that
[ __ ] yeah I always say one day I'm gonna
try Tantra I'm gonna learn how to like
completely like guys say that you can
have like an internal orgasm I've choked
one back Wow just got to grab the base
right before impact and he's really hard
but what if you cause an injury it's why
I've only done it a couple times I'm oh
if you broke your own dead cuz you
grabbed it too hard life would not be
worth living can you imagine that not
having your dick come anymore for the
rest of your life and knowing that
you're thinking like this is what I
can't lose yeah I can't
embarrassing myself you gotta choose
between being blind or having your dick
break oh no question
what would you say give me the [ __ ]
stick and the dog
[Laughter]
[Music]